okay I am streaming the classical shield
arena on me chess my opponent is playing
an Alekhine which I haven't studied much
of at least in recent years I'll play AE
five I'll just play what I think is the
most principled move I'm gonna fix the
framing because things are a little bit
off so we can see the seed numbers it's
a little bit better okay let's play d4
so yeah the following games are going to
be much slower than normal with how many
minutes per person 20 minutes per person
ten second increments this will be a lot
more chill a lot more time to talk about
what's going on in the position time to
calculate consider multiple options time
to interact with the chat - so okay I
know Knight f3 is the main move I'll
admit I don't know too much beyond at
least the first few moves
pretty sure Bishop e2 here at some point
why it is supposed to take on d6
actually I do remember a setup to play
involving c4 or b3 Knight bTW - Bishop
b2 so I'll probably go for that I guess
it's just a matter of executing it
properly
maybe I start with c4 let's start with
c4 well make sure people can hear me
decently my mic should be like might
flop around a little bit but mostly it's
okay so I'm expecting Knight d6 here
usually black will go like Nike 696 and
trying these develop
I'm thinking I can take because I don't
want to deal with blinds where black
takes on e5 and black can't take with
the Queen or the bishop because I have
c5 forking no I think I'll just castle
we should no black cannot win a pawn on
c4 for multiple reasons there'd be Queen
a4 check or there it'd be Bishop takes
p7 in the end so I'll play Knight bTW -
and I remember the setup is pretty solid
because the main thing that White has to
be concerned about in this line is
ensuring that c4 and d4 are covered
which okay they're currently defended
but black is challenging the center I
don't want the D file to open up I think
c5 is most principled and then I believe
the bishop belongs on b2 even though
it's blocked by the pawn it plays some
role in defending the pawn and then I
also remember there is an idea to play
bishops he 3 B 4 B 5 so I think I'll
start with that I have some vague memory
of blitz games where my opponent would
play Bishop f6 and then I would blunder
some Knight takes e5 move because of the
pin so I'm expecting Bishop f6 here I'll
probably respond with b4 he owe me and
the chats
welcome back he owe me and other people
in the chats load Phi L term in adore GN
Patrick what surd series tower
Sears Tower are you from Chicago haven't
heard that name in a while also thanks
to the subs or is it just one son Yeol
Xin mana appreciate the sub
so 9 X 6 so ok 94 might be coming this
very common type of plan for this
structure whenever there's pawns on d4
and c5 and the black pawn on d5
the two main plans for black r e5 and 94
either together or separate the money
for it's kind of annoying
I'm thinking I'll just allow it like be
4 and if 94 Queen b3 give up the bishop
pair I could also play 95 here 95 we
trade on e to that 94 can't be played an
e5 can't be played but 95 he can take
first I take so I'm attacking the knight
he has to take on e 2 I take back d4 is
some in turn a so as of 97 there which
is looks most natural I played before
and I think I'm happy so 95 9 takes e5
pawn takes e5 Bishop takes e to Queen
take C to D for I feel like is maybe
kind of critical then maybe I just
played I could take on f6 takes on c3
takes on e7 actually that looks good so
I attack the Queen and the rook so 95
let's do it
you have to be careful when I play this
move because I'm allowing c5 to be a bit
more week and also e5 to be potentially
a week but I don't see anything wrong
with this so hopefully it's okay
you got just can't wait to see all the
arrows today well I hope we're off to a
good start at least arrow wise series
tower is not from Chicago probably
because they renamed the Sears Tower the
Willis Tower
okay good to see new people - hi insane
and a lot more people so I'll try and
stay focused on the game
but black is already needing to make
some decision we might see Bishop f5
just keeping tension but that would make
me happy fish about five I probably just
continued efore d5 and I think 95
accomplishes some like preventive play
because I'm preventing black from
playing a5 anytime soon
I'm also preventing or at least
discouraging 94 in many mines
I insane with a sub for some reasons the
sound is not working
now usually there is sound alerts you
have to like move it up also what
happened to the a zombie person now
something is weird with though alerts
okay so this is what I calculated my
take on e5 expecting Bishop take C - I'd
have to take back
no 97 yeah so e for was basically the
end of my calculation what else to play
and these pawns even though they're kind
of overextended they're well supported
and this looks very reasonable
black is a little bit low on space
imagining like b6 which is a common type
of pawn break I could play c6 and then
night be a b5 and this night is very
much restricted
okay so rook c8 he's probably preparing
b6 so it's a question can I prevent b6
okay maybe distract a curry play on some
other area of the board even though
black seems passive he's pretty solid
there's no clear weaknesses Queen b5 b6
t 698 probably doesn't work
the problem is when black plays b6 I
probably have to take and then black
starts unraveling so it's a question how
did I get the most out of my next couple
moves because whatever I play he's going
to play b6 and then I'll have another
move something Bishop t4 b6 I can't play
Knight b3 sadly am Bishop t4 b6 I
probably have to take he take back with
knights and then something like a three
not the most exciting variation 23
looking for resources here and I'm not
seeing much might be three be six Queen
a six so I think I should start with
Bishop d4 I'm like - where's my bishop
along though
so Bishop might belong on D - maybe
night no pawn is pinned it's thinking
might be three Bishop b2 but there's no
time for it and Brooke Brooke FC one
also a month ragazzi one b6 takes takes
and then maybe a four and gives it a
five I think I'll go for this
because the C file is going to open I
want both rooks on the Queen side and
after b6 the one sort of advantage I'm
gonna try to be playing for is my queen
side majority like after b6 and we trade
I'll have two on one so the goal will be
to advance make a passed pawn and
somehow win but I'm playing a good
player from Azerbaijan hauser by Jean's
very has very rich chess culture very
strong country in terms of like their
Olympiad team they hosted the Olympiad
and they had like four teams play or
something okay so I have to take
expecting Knight takes Queen takes is
also possible if Queen takes I might
have to play a three ok Knight takes and
now a four
did I just blunder I may have just
blundered I think I just blundered
I played a for Low's too quickly oh but
he didn't okay so I I thought maybe you
could play d4 and then kick my bishop
and win the pawn maybe he didn't see us
okay so now b5 looks attractive I mean
this is a whole plan of playing a4 is to
just put the pawns on light squares d4
shouldn't be a problem anymore
and now there's a plan of maneuvering
the knight to c6 I'll probably start
with Knight B 3 no threats right Bishop
a6 rook c2 or Bishop e3 Roxy to
it's some air conditioning on I have to
learn Celsius all the temperatures are
in Celsius up to 21
okay so I have a night maneuver planned
Knight d4 to c6 I don't know what Locke
is doing then maybe he'll double up
rooks on the C file but if I get the
Knight to c6 then the C file is
essentially closed whenever you have a
pawn defending a minor piece which is
blocking the open file for the opponent
there's a term for that in chess it's
called a four-post similar to an outpost
where the four posts essentially has its
own strengths because then I control
when the file opens if I get the knight
to c6 I double up on the C file and then
at some point move the Knights it could
work but he also kind of has a four-post
to c4 so the C file could close down
pretty quickly if we both have floor
posts
I mean the other benefit I have in this
position is pawn on e5 maybe it gives me
some attacking potential like some day
after night c6 like queen g4 lifts the
rook over and mates Bishop T to Bishop
h6 as this enough arrows yesterday the
arrows were very successful as I was
drawing them and my opponents were
resigning like on my move I would draw
arrows and then they just resigned look
at Queen b7 what's the plan wants to
play a six you can allow it
if a six I'll have some choices I'll
consider like rook
I either looked to be one consider
knight c6 Bishop c5 I think it's time
for knight c6 if knight c6 a6
looks a little bit shaky but then I
probably play rook could be one there's
not a three there but then Ravi three
lots of trades okay worst-case scenario
I have not a five if I need it
let's do it
it's a tense position my night looks
pretty but at least for the meantime
it's probably just a decoration it's not
actually doing that much but I do want
to maintain it so he does go for a six
now it's a question which rook to move
to be one or do I play Bishop d4 Bishop
d4 also playable
Bishop d4 is kind of a bailout move
these 93 lines are complicated and
difficult to calculate like rook be one
night a three night a five Queen b6 rook
b3 should be okay with other rook also
not sure what you're up to move
you're like I should move the Seabrook
let's play Brooke cb1 okay we're trading
I play you're exceeding 1 because for
this case say I want my rook having a
file in this case a sevens guarded but
maybe you later in my Ripken activates
but okay he's challenging the file
essentially threatening to win a pawn
thinking I might have to take
rook takes eight rook takes eight this
should be four we trade this game is
gonna be a fight what I'm not sure of
the valuation even it's still like a bit
unbalanced takes takes there's a d4
and I want to play Bishop d4 because my
bishops just not that useful in this
position well I'm concerned that b5 is
gonna turn into more of a weakness and
it is a strength his light is so strong
what else do I do not much else to do
okay
we're trading Jodi for at least mine if
my knight comes to d4 then it will be
defend the b5 pawn so b5 should be solid
I might consider if my King isn't too
unsafe I'll go for f4 to reinforce ie 5
I would like a couple extra moves to
play h3 King h2 ensuring my king or the
the diagonal can't be exploited
expecting Bishop takes d4 so we might
see Queen b6
Queen b6 I would like to make 97 work I
don't think it works so okay so we trade
so these are the two pawns I want to
keep defended b5 is very well defended
b5 at least for now it's defended
this is a crazy thing about classical
chest compared to the chests I've
recently been playing like we play this
holy opening middle game I still have a
lot of time left for the resulting
endgame games like this they can take a
lot of energy you have to be really
involved with like every single move h6
makes me happy I mean maybe it's useful
for for black because he's creating lift
but okay he's essentially giving me some
time to do something I might just play
h3 here can consider h4 I'm imagining
some eventual plan of like h3 rook b3
rook g3 and then like all-out attack
put the King on h2 the Queen on g4 the
Paul enough for let's start with h3
useful moves for both of us essentially
I'm just putting the ball back in his
court if he plays aged six it means that
it's maybe not entirely sure what to do
he wants to draw let's play this out
it's imbalanced enough where I knew that
of course I want to win
oh he's higher either than me sure got
classical readings are not as inflated
compared to other paintings on the site
what's his blitz rating there's a lot of
blitz plays a couple hundred classical
games the one thing about like over the
board tournament play is that you have
to offer a draw after making your move
so you make your move offer the draw hit
the clock but on line play you can offer
a draw whenever so when he offers a draw
on his turn obviously I'm not going to
accept it but if I wanted to consider
accepting it all at the very least wait
until he makes his move and then decide
it's happened to me a few times in
tournaments where people will offer
draws on their own turn and the
positions like complicated enough and
there's no clear draw then I just won't
respond I'll just I'll just keep
thinking and then their time will be
ticking doesn't happen too often though
I wonder if he's just waiting for me to
like respond either accept or decline
it's wait until he Flags you know at
least there's some clear plan I think
like if it's my move again I probably go
for king h2 like my next few moves are
King H to f4 okay now I have to defend
the Knights I wanted to play queen g4
but that hangs e5 so how do I defend the
names maybe I should take the drop Queen
b6 good move
I could play neither three but my knight
wants to stay on d4 there's not too many
moves here actually for white rook D
one's a move maybe Rick do you one does
my ripple like my Brooks not really
actually doing anything on b1 I nights
staying on d4 so rook t1 then that gives
me time to go through with my plan and
I'll have like rook d3 with g3
eventually just wondering can you do
anything on the Queen side play rook a3
don't think that does too much yeah
let's play with t1
I mean neither a three would be extreme
like going after the pawn but then it
opens up my clean defending the pawn and
he has the whole open file to himself
but really the only square I mean maybe
we'll go for okay for setting up some
like discovery
he plays Roque for I don't think there's
the threat and just play king h2 I'm
thinking that okay he plays her okay
three
so whenever the player plays a move like
this first question is what is a threat
is there a threat I don't see the threat
so let's play king h2 if you ever
attacks along with Queen c7 I have a
four ah
then there's work III also have like
Knight f3 or rook e1 so there are
options
so my king is off the diagonal meaning
f4 is a very real possibility coming
soon and if I get that for and then
opens up ideas of f5 some late middle
game attack it's always scary though to
attack on the same side that your Castle
Don because sometimes you attack with
pawns and then you overextend and then
you regret it so we'll see what happens
also wondering if I play f4 and then
eventually trade he goes for Queen c7
I wonder if he's watching he heard my
idea f4 key three looks appetizing
I'm pretty sure I can just allow Ricki
three I continue with queen g4
I mean the RIC is really active
Ricky for
calculating some line f4 rookie three
queen g4 rookie four and I take C six
and I'm winning like three pawns I don't
think that's enough
it's bits from coward pawn and axe
villager is in the chat okay focus
f4 wait
saying the word focus doesn't actually
make me focus f4 rookie three queen g4
rookie for ninety six pack rookie for
maybe like ripped III then it's weird
oh there's also 93 to be concerned about
and I just move the Brooke okay let's
play out for it does more good than harm
oh yeah there was noise for the bits I
guess there's just no noise for subs
yeah sometimes stream Labs gets lazy or
something ok so I gave him the e3 Square
but I'm strengthening my pawn I'm
wondering if I get the chance to trade
rooks who would that benefit or maybe it
just makes it closer to a draw probably
makes it more Josh maybe even benefits
black trading rooks probably makes this
a bit weaker so if Queens got traded
it's a king upon ending Red King Knight
pawn ending the pawn can be very weak
so this game could go the distance for
not agreeing to an early draw then it's
gonna be played out we've each used just
just over half our time
and for both of us like the main
strategy it sounds simple but the main
strategy is just finding the optimal
squares for the Queen Knight and rook so
Queen b6 okay
well now if I play queen g4 there's 93
with a fork I really want to like take
on c4 make that work somehow but it just
gives it Queen four nothing about a five
a five rookie three probably no good
riff d3 was not a move I wanted to play
but it is an option
g4 makes no sense Queen musics actually
makes me kind of stuck
I'm just looking for moves here okay I
don't really see much my rooks tied down
to the night the Knights tied down to
the pawn my queen has some ability so
where does the Queen if I could place
the Queen anywhere on the board I place
it on a AIDS or before so maybe Queenie
one when you want to be four to e78
so Queenie one it's a move
there's might be two might be two would
be some weird repetition rook d2 night
c4
just as difficult maybe I should over
defend the night first like we have to
also have Queens now Quincy to 93 oh but
then Quincy it
so maybe Quincy - what's wrong
there's also some funny line Queen e1
night b2 night c2 counter-attacking I
think we need one like worst case
scenario it's a draw he tries to repeat
I also have ver k1 over k2 one half or
93
let's play Queenie one at least there's
some plan I forgot I made tea like right
before I started streaming made a nice
cup of tea it's gonna be really strong
now hopefully it makes me strong that's
what happens with strong tea right very
strong and lukewarm so Queen B 4 have
some plan Queen D 4 with infiltration to
eventually win this pong and the goal is
to at least make black think such a long
game
that's a nature of classical chess I'm
imagining this tournament is 10 hours
long it's possible to play this whole
tournament and play like less than 15
games if all the games go to the full
distance I have to plug in my laptop
there we go I'm sure almost died
Patrick jmt asking why don't I come
visit Tokyo next month I was so close to
visiting Tokyo the friend there who
works at the Embassy but it didn't make
sense it's too out of the way well it
had to look a couple more flights that
books my flight from Bangkok to Europe I
was so I would have had to go from like
either Thailand or Indonesia to Tokyo
and then back to to Thailand would have
been too much but it's it's very high on
my bucket list to visit Japan and not
just Tokyo let's heard there's just so
many things to see in Japan and they
have the best green tea
Stephen is Daedalus I did not say this
is going to be a 10 hour stream I'll
stream I don't know
I don't know what I said in my stream
schedule I think I said a couple hours
we'll see hopefully this game doesn't
completely drain me he's still thinking
so this could turn into some like
eventual time scramble rookie 3 so it's
gonna get sharp it's allowing Queen B 4
wants to play rookie four probably this
is probably a line I should have
calculated
so Queen before Orakei 496 vertex f4
doesn't look good
looki for
never k1 ideas - there's some crazy line
and I don't have much time to calculate
the queen bee for a rookie for her okay
one he wins d4 I have rook e8 and Queen
f8 I don't think that works so I think
I'm gonna sack up on wait Queen before
working for Knight f3 takes work a1 rook
takes up three looks very scary Queen
before rookie 4
yeah I'd like to include pg3 queen bee
for a rookie for 9x3 bro takes off for
King g3 you play workout 5 lose another
pawn I'm running low on time too all
this can turn very bad I mean if I want
to play safe I have Queen h4 and if
rookie for Queen f2 then there's 93
Queen h4 rookie for waits for a rookie
for maybe Knight f3 right away Queen
takes b5 Queen d8 King h7 you like Queen
h4 gives me more options actually having
access to e7 and e8
I think I'm gonna go for this Matt
doesn't look right though
but I have to do something
getting to the point where I feel like
I'll be happy with the draw because I
feel like I'm gonna be in trouble very
soon
there's actually some funny idea I'm
looking at it's a drawing line rookie
for Knight f3 Queen takes b5 Queen d8
King h7 than Queen back to h4 with a
simple threat of Knight f5 maybe that
doesn't work though just moves her rook
to e2 what black still has to be
concerned about things like rookie for
Knight f3 Queen digs b5 I've worked a 1
the combination of rook a 1 in Knight g5
could be some sort of mating net so
we're both trying to attack on the King
side in that line thankfully he's
getting a long time lower on time
you know i'm expecting a rookie for it
but maybe there's some other moves he's
considering they see what else black
considers if he wants to stop okay he's
doing it so Queen off two is a move but
I'm just gonna go for this sacking the
b-pawn which is sad it's my only pass
pawn it was an outside past pawn
I'll see if he takes it
because the question is if you take some
b5 do I check first do I play rock a 1
first choices choices
I don't have a very bad feeling about
this position though we'll see what
happens
calculating Queen digs b5 Queen da King
h7 rook a 1 or a ticks f4 and then rook
e8 sacking two pawns for some check on
the back reading
it's probably just losing for me Queen
e3 so he doesn't take the beep on he's
going after the F pawn wants to take the
check and trade Queen's King g3 might
actually be a playable move here I can
still consider rook a one okay one we
trade check probably not good I will say
I've rook rook a4 seems to slow so King
g3 what's a little bit ridiculous
there could be a problem with that move
be a very big problem with it
[Music]
maybe it's okay though I actually don't
see anything immediately losing for
whites there's one move that kind of
initially scared me I'm gonna assume
that he's watching so I don't want to
say anything that gives some ideas okay
ten second increments should help me
least a little bit I should have
considered b6y then considered b6 would
have been nice
then he wouldn't be able to trade Queens
and he wouldn't be able to take on b6
his queen da check I should have played
b6 he had rook takes off forever than
Queens e8 b7 oh wait no Knight takes b6
and his queen defends from afar okay
it's not a huge miss g5 so this is what
I was initially scared of I think I can
just take on each six he takes on that
four I play King F 2 and I'm threatening
to take on g5 and he has okay he has
perpetual so we might actually draw this
unless he mates me somehow I don't see
how he made Smee
well it's getting sharp getting very
sharp it's both our Kings are very
precarious have to play this will need
legal move and they're the perpetual is
going back and forth like this which he
might have to do because I'm wanting to
take on g5 that's hard to defend g5 I
can trade Queens I'll be so happy
maybe now I offer a draw he declines it
you know wants to play for a win
okay that's good to know that probably
not considering the draw or if you want
say your whole just repeats
first place has 21 points Wow this is my
first game you fix the board layout I
guess you can get by like the zhurqis a
bunch beating people quickly and not
slowly so now okay we essentially have
like blitz chess with ten second
increments but it feels like there's
more on the line compared to blitz
because we've both spent like so much
time leading up to this position I
really don't want to like spend so much
energy on this game and lose
that's a scary move I just move the rook
like rook a 1 what does he want to do
work a 1 where it's a check
g4 shouldn't work I'm threatening maiden
1 after this he's probably gonna play
like 91
I'm so confused what's he threatening
my g4
I take and I run it was 93 oh he wants
to trap no jacking my queen he just gets
mated maybe he missed her okay one
now he's low on time if you liked
offering the draw was a good
psychological decision to prompted him
to maybe over push for a win
basically what I did okay so he's Wade
this is just complete is it completely
when I take he's 91 check by winning g5
now this is much better
I have anything let's go for this it's
gonna play 91 King king he won he takes
I take she probably just gained time
anyone feels a little bit unsafe but
then at least his queen will be tied
down to defending the night
and then I take here so I can check him
in gain time now I have I control if I
take the perpetual by him up upon maybe
I just checked Jack Knight g5 and he
can't defend f7 this is something not
even to think about because if I want to
I can repeat and Knight g5 what does he
do he's probably enough to start like
checking me and pray for a perpetual I
just run to my shelter I g5 I have time
he has Queen h4 and I take the Knights
the problem is whatever Queen check I
just take the night and he has no night
checks and he defends f7 I mean I'm
threatening made into like this as well
so this should just be winning Queen h4
takes there's no way there's perpetual
here
because they just run to each to
kind of feel bad for him the position
was should have been clearly better
somehow
so now I run I can also like run to g3
and lock with a knight somehow but h2
seems very safe everything was defended
- yeah so you prevented me from moving
to g1 but you can access each - like
this I won't creep move okay
I feel bad no I don't really feel too
bad for him really threw that one away
but it's goes to show chess is brutal
like he was on the verge it seems like
he's on the verge of winning I was
thinking he can some line here Mouse's
board was I thinking some knight takes
yeah Knight takes e5 this is what I was
a little bit scared of impeccable king
let us of thank you I was scared of this
because it's just a better endgame for
luck I would take on g5 and then he has
ripped b5 in the end and he's winning
this pawn it would be on be three on two
but black having two connected pastors
and this should be it should be winning
it like high level play but very good
winning chances for black thanks for the
bits you got Jes 95 what about rook a
one still says Patrick GMT it will point
and bits from heart wise and noodle
every time some Lions oh just now but
there's a delay so now it was like 10
seconds ago
wait 95 ah I see what you mean 90 95
rook a 190 well maybe this is possible I
was so focused on taking on g5
yeah this actually looks possible it's
surprising the counterplay is strong
curious what the computer would say in
93 was really bad just throws the game
away I think the computer is just saying
Wow can we treat her find some crazy g4
move probably influenced by Nathan
okay so computer find some slightly
better endgame yeah okay that was was a
long game if every game is gonna be like
that I don't think I'm gonna play too
many games that was Alekhine I was
relatively pleased with the opening
maybe I just like overestimated this
position
cuz rook c8 b6 was strong and don't
think I had any advantage so computer
says I should just play b4 and then if
94 Queen c2 okay yeah this is kind of
one line I think I mentioned giving up
the bishop here I didn't really want to
give up the bishop pair goes Bishop f6
and he five looks scary but maybe I have
like a 4 B 5 okay
fun game actually stressful game
well back to tournaments I have two
points the top 300 I'm not sure how I'm
gonna like structure this when I upload
this to youtube because usually I just
upload the full stream that I might
upload just game by game so I if I
upload just that game YouTube people I
hope you guys enjoyed that stay tuned
for the next game which is starting any
second now